pharmacy truck i hit the other night on
its way to okc
i'm gonna need you to hop out and open
up the back
whoever it was knew exactly what they
were looking for
stop looking at me be cool be cool
so why do you do it
what's in our blood
hey sweet boy
how'd it go
yeah that's what i heard
hey happy birthday buddy thank you have
you met lawrence yet nice to meet you
adam walker doing 25 for murder and
conspiracy
anything major went down her name always
came up
so what's your wife think of this she
knows who she married i think they
really understand how far her reach goes
she wants us cleaning up
i'll do it
who's there
alex and white
what sent you i had a red
follow me
how much is this job
10
every mother grouper oh man flies in
from the middle east
they bring back cash deals they don't
report
and we do this we're done that's it
i see that look in your eye like you're
up to something i know what she turned
you into
there
strap up
[Applause]
[Music]
you might have to make some difficult
choices
[Music]
you